move over jared leto it's time for
joaquin phoenix to take a turn as dc's
clown prince of crime
as we've known for months now the walk
the line actor will be playing an
alternate version of the character for
director todd phillips in an upcoming
standalone origin movie
simply titled joker the project got the
green light from warner brothers in july
2018.
in the time since phillips has teased
audiences with behind-the-scenes looks
of phoenix and the role from the movie's
new york city-based shoot
with plenty of paparazzi footage also in
the wild showing the actor and crew at
work
official glimpses of phoenix have
included a costume test in red
white and blue makeup as well as a photo
of the star in his joker costume
relaxing between takes overall the
earlier sneak peeks painted a picture of
a joker far removed from the green
haired purple suited interpretations
that we've seen before
according to some writers they were
almost too different as a result
there's a new theory gaining traction
based around one question
is joaquin phoenix really playing the
joker so far we've been told that
phoenix will be playing arthur fleck
a stand-up comedian who loses his temper
sanity and grip on reality after bombing
with audiences and failing to launch a
legitimate career
the idea goes that flex agent of terror
isn't the joker but is instead a
predecessor of the joker
an inspiration for the character are
more familiar with writing for cinema
blend
writer adam holmes argues that arthur is
not the batman rival that we know
but rather a mentally unhinged man who
inspires the real clown prince of crime
later on
holmes grounds his theory and the fact
that phoenix's joker movie is set to
feature a middle-aged arthur a young
bruce
and distiller life thomas wayne existing
in the same world at the same time
at least that's what the situation looks
like provided that flashbacks aren't a
big part of the movie's story
based on the casting of dante pereira
olsen the young bruce wayne is likely
between the ages of 8 and 12 years old
with parents who haven't yet been killed
arthur on the other hand
is assumed to be roughly 40 to 45 years
old it's an age gap that raises serious
questions about the potential rivalry
between batman and the joker if the
movie's bruce grows up to be batman like
we expect
phoenix's version of the joker could be
upwards of 70 years old by the time
bruce starts his career
as a caped crusader historically batman
and the joker have been major
influencers on each other
serving as each other's polar opposite
one is an agent of order
the other an agent of chaos and they're
usually around the same age
the joker movie is clearly switching
things up from the source material in a
number of ways
with the character of arthur fleck being
an original creation with no direct
comic book analog
so it's possible that this universe
would just have a joker much older than
its batman but it's also possible that
arthur is a sort of proto-joker
never meant to fight batman at all
rumors about the plot of joker suggests
that the unhinged clown-faced arthur
will inspire a city-wide crime wave
whipping others into a felonious frenzy
his actions just might serve as
inspiration for criminals of the future
trying to live up to his chaotic ideal
in the comic books other characters have
taken up the role of batman to live up
to bruce wayne's example
and the villains take on the names of
their evil predecessors all the time
it's entirely possible that arthur is
just setting a standard for future
jokers to live up to
i'm an idea adding fuel to the theory is
the fact that this interpretation of the
joker has existed before
recently getting play in the fox tv
series gotham there the joker is
represented by the villainous twin
veleska brothers who played joker like
psychopaths without ever adopting the
name joker on screen
for several seasons gotham's agent of
chaos was jerome veleska
an unhinged and nearly unkillable
psychopath when jerome was finally
dispatched for good his brother jeremiah
promptly took over
playing a more cold and collected
version of the clown prince of crime
the idea of multiple jokers is something
that's also been explored in the comic
books with examples including dc rebirth
and the upcoming batman 3 joker
storyline
written by jeff johns the joker is a
character that lends himself well to
these kind of radical new
interpretations with his backstory and
his name
always being inconsistent across dozens
of stories and comics movies and tv
shows
it's been made clear that the identity
of the joker is irrelevant compared to
what he represents
in that sense maybe there is no real
joker that's a joke great's comedy
we'll find out for sure what arthur's
story is when joker hits theaters on
october 4th
2019.